An aquatic bromance, horrors of the deep,
and an AI daddy? The long-awaited trailer for
"Aquaman and the Lost Kingdom" is packed with
details that might have swum right past you.
Not only is Aquaman back for "Aquaman and the
Lost Kingdom," but the DC sequel expands the
fish-friendly hero's wardrobe, putting a spin on
the classic blue stealth suit from the comics.
The blue suit debuted in 1986's "Aquaman" #1,
and its ability to allow Aquaman to blend in
while underwater proved to be a contrast to
his iconic orange and green outfit. As with all
superhero costume changes, the blue camouflage
suit has its fans and detractors. However,
it's hard to not appreciate a nod
to a deep piece of DC Comics lore.
It seems that Jason Momoa and James Wan
are fans of the blue camouflage suit,
as the "Aquaman and the Lost Kingdom" trailer
gives a great look at the hero's new costume.
In the trailer, we see Aquaman donning his new
dark-blue suit, using its camouflage technology,
which seemingly makes him invisible, to
break into the desert prison housing Orm.
Although it probably won't be around for
long, simply referencing Aquaman's comic
book wardrobe change will surely be enough to
satisfy diehard fans. And it's always possible
he's wearing the suit in other scenes in
the trailer. You just...can't see him.
At long last, "Aquaman and the Lost Kingdom"
sees the return of DC's favorite couple. Well,
maybe not exactly. For those wondering,
Amber Heard is definitely reprising her
role as the Queen of Atlantis. Her
highly publicized defamation trial
involving ex-husband Johnny Depp caused
a backlash, with fans even calling for
her replacement. But lo and behold, she is
in at least one shot of the new trailer.
The majority of the footage shows
Arthur's relationship with his
reluctant half-brother Orm as they team
up to save Atlantis from Black Manta.
"Good job, old brother. High five."
"Do not call me brother."
So, where does that leave Mera? It's hard to say.
In a succession of increasingly fast-paced action
shots, Mera appears in only one brief moment,
where she seems to be trying to break through a
window underwater. Even when Arthur appears happy
with his baby, Mera is hardly in the picture.
James Wan has admitted to Entertainment Weekly
that the film doesn't focus on Arthur's romantic
entanglements, but instead on the two brothers.
With a scaled-down role in the movie's story,
it makes sense then why she doesn't appear
prominently in the trailer. By skipping ahead
four years, viewers will have missed out on a
lot of the development between Arthur and Mera,
but hopefully, we at least get
to see her be with her family.
One of the most appealing aspects of the world
of "Aquaman" is that there's no shortage of odd
creatures and humanoid hybrids that can come
into play when Arthur Curry is in Atlantis.
The trailer for "Aquaman and the Lost Kingdom"
offers a glimpse of plenty of new additions,
including some hammerhead shark people flanking
Arthur and Orm while they're underwater.
These could very well be some
associates of King Shark,
who entered the DCEU in "The Suicide Squad."
"New dumb friends!"
But according to some reports, the movie
is set to feature the character of Karshon,
another shark from DC comics who rapidly evolved
to human-like intelligence and telepathy
after being hit with a dose of radiation.
So even though they look similar, we
wouldn't count on King Shark showing
up. He might be too weird
even for an Aquaman movie.
The "Aquaman and the Lost Kingdom" trailer holds
plenty of references to the aquatic
superhero's past, but one of its more
veiled references may actually be a nod
to the real-life history of his actor.
"Four years ago, I was basically
unemployed. A wanderer with no home."
This line about the hero's history
actually mirrors that of Jason Momoa,
who has revealed in interviews that
he struggled with a prolonged period
of unemployment after his breakout stint as Khal
Drogo on "Game of Thrones." He once told InStyle:
"I couldn't get work. It's very challenging when
you have babies and you're completely in debt."
"Where are you going to put Drogo in a comedy?
It's like, where the hell do you put him?"
A bit later in the trailer, Aquaman
declares that he finally got a job
as the king of Atlantis. In a similar vein,
Momoa's struggle to find work improved when
he was cast as Aquaman in the DCEU.
Momoa's final appearance on "Game of
Thrones" was in 2012, while his debut as
Aquaman came in 2016 — a four-year gap.
Is this an intentional reference to Momoa's story?
Maybe not, but it's hard to ignore the parallels.
At least one thing is clear from the "Aquaman
and the Lost Kingdom" trailer: director James
Wan is letting his horror roots show more than
ever. While the first "Aquaman" movie had some
scary sequences of its own, the horror dial is
clearly getting cranked up to 11 for the sequel,
as viewers can see what are ostensibly zombified
Atlanteans rising up to do battle with Atlantis.
What casual fans may not have picked up on is that
Wan appears to finally be getting an opportunity
to make the horror-tinged Atlantis story that
he has long desired. At one point in time,
the esteemed horror director was slated to direct
an "Aquaman" spin-off called "The Trench," which
would focus on the sinister beings that
Aquaman faces off against in his first
movie. Unfortunately, the project was canned,
leaving eager fans worried that Wan's take on
a more overtly horror-inspired DC project would
not come to fruition. Thankfully, this latest
trailer suggests that he managed to make his
wish come true, albeit in a different form.
It seems that "Aquaman and the Lost
Kingdom" may be drawing more from
Wan's scrapped "The Trench" movie than
some may have expected. The director
once revealed that the canceled film was
stealthily going to feature Black Manta,
whose gruesome story is now front-and-center
here. He has also teased that the "Aquaman"
sequel will bring back other concepts from "The
Trench." Speaking to ComicBook.com, Wan said:
"Listen, I feel like everything I come up with,
everything I do, if I come up with
something that I don't end up using,
that doesn't mean that I cannot be
inspired to use that in a different way."
Perhaps one of the most interesting
details in the "Aquaman and the Lost
Kingdom" trailer happens as the first look
wraps up. Pay close attention to the final
moments as the credits for the film come
up and viewers will see that Jason Momoa
has received a "Story by" credit alongside
James Wan, David Leslie Johnson-McGoldrick,
and Thomas Pa'a Sibbett. While Momoa didn't
write the script, "The Lost Kingdom" does
feature story ideas from the actor. During an
interview with The Hollywood Reporter in 2022,
Momoa expressed just how excited he was to
have played a part in the sequel's narrative,
revealing that he wrote a 50-page treatment for
the project. Teasing the sequel, the actor said:
"It's got my heart in it."
How did the writing process start?
In an interview with Drew Barrymore,
Momoa candidly discussed what it
was like to cook up the sequel,
revealing that he worked on the first treatment,
and Wan and Johnson-McGoldrick finished it off.
"After we ended the first one, I went in with my
writing partner and we dreamed up the second one."
Black Manta is more powerful than ever in
"Aquaman and the Lost Kingdom" thanks to his
acquisition of the Black Trident. However,
that may not be the only upgrade he gets in
the sequel. It may be a bit of a stretch,
but around the 0:52 mark of the trailer,
he gets inside a vessel that could be a loose
adaptation of the Mecha Manta from the comics.
"I'm gonna kill Aquaman and
destroy everything he holds dear."
The Mecha Manta is a fairly new addition to Black
Manta's arsenal in the comics, coming into play
originally in "Aquaman" Volume 8 #51, which came
out in 2019. It's an artificial intelligence
gifted to the supervillain by Lex Luthor that
emulates the thoughts of Black Manta's deceased
father. It also doesn't hurt that it's encased in
a giant robot capable of destroying its opponents.
Granted, it's hard to tell from
the trailer whether it is, in fact,
an adaptation of the Mecha Manta. It
could just be another random vessel
Black Manta uses to wage his war
against sea dwellers. It's worth
noting that audiences saw Black Manta's
father die in the first "Aquaman" movie.
"Damn you!"
"Go."
Given how the sequel seems to emphasize the
importance of family, it wouldn't be out of
the question for dear old dad to come back into
the mix. Then again, there's likely already so
much going on in the sequel that adding an AI
layer could make things even more convoluted.
The trailer for "Aquaman and the Lost Kingdom"
is filled to the brim with narrative threads
that are worth unraveling. While Arthur Curry
is definitely struggling with being a father in
this cinematic outing, he's also dealing
with being a good brother. At the end of
the first "Aquaman," Curry's half-brother
Orm is imprisoned after his gambit to take
over Atlantis flops. While Curry and
Orm were never on the best of terms,
the final moments of "Aquaman" cemented
the animosity the two had for one another.
In "The Lost Kingdom," Orm is surprisingly back,
and the vibe he shares with Curry is nothing short
of hilarious. The trailer shows Curry having
no choice but to break Orm out of prison so
they can stop Black Manta together — making
the sequel a true family affair. From there,
the trailer makes it a point to hammer
home how Orm and Aquaman are on this
strange journey together, whether
they like it or not. Needless to say,
the bromance vibes are oozing thanks to
the chemistry between Wilson and Momoa.
While speaking with Entertainment Weekly,
director James Wan candidly discussed how
he always wanted "Aquaman 2" to focus on
the two estranged brothers. He revealed:
"The second movie was always going to
be Arthur and Orm. So, the first was a
romance action-adventure movie, the second
one is a bromance action-adventure movie."